a recent economy-wide consumer prices
went up more than expected in January
there was an expectation that the
Consumer Price Index would go up 0.3
percent it ended up going up almost
twice that amount 0.5 percent and the
Consumer Price Index it's an index it
doesn't measure the price of everything
in the economy it's an index that takes
sort of a basic basket of goods things
that most people buy and sort of need
for their for the maintain for the I
don't know what you would call it the
support of their day-to-day lifestyle
and that is tracked by the Consumer
Price Index and this includes things
like gasoline what's called shelter
clothing medical care food and the
prices of those items went up in January
more than anticipated so with these
stories it's good to first do like a
totally standard neoclassical economic
analysis right which is we've had
economic growth over the last many years
we've had a reduction in unemployment
this means that wages have started to
trickle up slightly in order to better
attract workers since the pool of
unemployed workers you can hire from has
become smaller and that means that in
response some of the prices of basic
goods are going to go up as a response
and sort of there you have it right so
now the question is is a period of
inflation starting that's the
neoclassical rational actor perfectly
efficient markets analysis however most
of us now have gotten beyond that
black-white sort of deterministic
understanding of economics number one
we've learned we're not good at making
economic predictions in general number
two we've learned that actors in the
economy are not actually totally
rational and number three we've learned
that the link between deficit and debt
and inflation is not as direct and hard
and fast as much of the American right
wants us to believe there's a totally
different argument that you can make
here you could look at this data and you
could say well
when you just dump a ton of cash onto
people who don't really need it and I'm
talking about the massive tax cuts for
the rich that Donald Trump's
administration recently passed
that's not economically stimulative
spending but it can have the effect of
driving up the price of goods now to be
clear I'm speculating because the more I
study economics and I've shared this
with you before the more I study
economics the more I learn how terrible
we are at making predictions and even at
pointing to causal relationships
relationships except in retrospect right
after we have an event humans are really
good at looking back and saying here is
a perfect coherent narrative about why
it happened but if we were actually so
good at it we'd be able to be better at
predicting what it is that's going to
happen ahead of time and were not we're
simply not so as far as action items if
you're in the camp that believes
inflation is coming we're about to have
major inflation in the United States
which will probably come with interest
rate increases from the Fed you might
want to get a mortgage sooner than later
right if you're thinking about in the
next three or four years buying a home
and getting a new mortgage if you
believe the narrative that inflation is
coming and is going to be accelerating
then that might be a reason to get that
mortgage sooner than later we'll follow
it right but rest assured that no matter
what happens if anything bad happens to
the economy
the current administration will blame
President Obama and if anything good
happens in the economy the current
administration will take 100 percent
credit for it and praise the great
Donald Trump for having turned things
around from where President Obama left
off that you can be sure of ahead of
time beyond that we're pretty terrible
at predicting anything you can discuss
this with us on our subreddit at david
pakman.com slash our IDI di t we'll take
a break we've got a great interview
coming up today and a lot more today's
program is sponsored in part by wink at
try wink comm slash Pakman spelled WI
and see my girlfriend
of wine and different types of wine and
whenever I'm assigned the task of going
to pick up a bottle of wine that we
would like or that would be an
appropriate bottle to bring to a dinner
where maybe fish is being served or
whatever I don't know what I'm doing and
that's why I really like the wink
service which makes it easy to get wines
that you will like they'll ship you
wines each month that are matched to
your tastes and personalized to you and
the way it works is if you go to try
wink comm slash Pakman you fill out
their palate profile quiz they ask you
very simple questions it's like six
questions how do you like your coffee
do you prefer coffe Fe or regular coffee
or whatever do you like raspberries or
blueberries simple questions that we
should all be able to answer and then
you start getting great wines
personalized to you delivered right to
your door as you drink more wines and
you rate more wines wink learns and you
get even better
personalized selections no membership
fees skip any month cancel anytime and
wink has a 100% satisfaction guarantee
so you never pay for a bottle you don't
like and for a limited time you can save
twenty bucks when you go to try wink
comm slash Pakman exciting that is tri
wink spelled T ry WI and C comm slash
Pakman for $20 off try wacom slash
Pakman don't embarrass yourself the way
I've done so many times being completely
clueless about wine